en el vídeo pasado mostré que las
razones de los lados de un triángulo de
30 60 90 si asumimos que la hipotenusa
vale x entonces el lado más corto tiene
longitud de x sobre 2 y el lado opuesto
al ángulo de 60 grados vale raíz de 3
por x sobre 2 otra manera de pensar en
esto bueno si el lado más corto vale 1
si el lado opuesto a la 9 60 grados vale
1 entonces el lado opuesto al ángulo de
60 grados vale raíz de 3 por 1 por lo
tanto bueno simplemente es raíz de 3
la hipotenusa será el doble del lado más
corto así que en este caso si este lado
vale 1 la hipotenusa vale 2 es el doble
de 1 por lo tanto este lado corresponde
al lado opuesto del ángulo de 30 grados
este al opuesto de 60 grados y este al
opuesto de la hipotenusa 90 grados en
general si tú ves un triángulo que tiene
esas razones entonces dice son muy bien
ese este es un triángulo de 30 60 y 90 o
puedes decir bueno me puedo yo basar en
las razones que yo conozco para
encontrar la longitud de un lado ahora
sólo como ejemplo si tú si tienes si
llegaras a ver un triángulo así donde
los lados son de 2 de 2 y 2 por raíz de
3 y 4 la razón de 2 y 2 raíz de 3 es uno
a raíz de 3 y la razón de 2 y 4 es lo
mismo que 1 a 2
esto debe ser entonces un triángulo de
30 60 90 claramente ahora en este vídeo
yo quiero introducirte a otro tipo de
triángulos que también es muy importante
este tipo de triángulo aparece en todas
partes
es un triángulo de 45 45 90
otra manera de verlo es como un
triángulo rectángulo que a la vez es
isósceles así que hago mi mejor intento
de dibujarlo obviamente no puedes tener
un triángulo rectángulo que es
equilátero porque un triángulo
equilátero todos sus ángulos miden 60
cierto pero si podrás tener un triángulo
rectángulo que es isósceles lo voy a
escribir aquí este es un triángulo
rectángulo isósceles y si es isósceles
eso quiere decir que dos de los lados
miden lo mismo cierto entonces estos dos
lados miden lo mismo y si eso sucede
entonces también los ángulos de la base
miden lo mismo si llamamos a la medida
de los ángulos x entonces sabemos los
siguientes sabemos que x más x más 90 es
igual a 180 x más x más 90 es igual a
180 si restamos 90 de ambos lados
entonces x x es igual a 90 luego 2x es
igual a 90 dividimos ambos lados entre
dos y obtenemos que x es igual a 45 así
que un triángulo rectángulo y sociales'
también puede ser llamado
uno de 45 45 90 ahora en este vídeo
yo quiero averiguar la razón entre los
lados de un triángulo de 45 45 90 justo
como lo hicimos en el vídeo pasado para
el triángulo de 30 60 90 aunque en este
caso sale casi directo porque es un
triángulo de 40 y 55 90 si llamamos a un
lado x entonces también el otro se llama
x porque si sociales
luego podemos aplicar el teorema de
pitágoras para averiguar la longitud de
la hipotenusa a la longitud de la
hipotenusa llamémosle cm y entonces
tenemos que x cuadrada más x cuadrada
cuando sumamos las longitudes de los
lados iguales tendrá que ser igual a c
al cuadrado por el teorema de pitágoras
sale directo de ahí y ahora obtenemos
que 2x al cuadrado es igual a sea al
cuadrado ahora podemos tomar la raíz de
ambos lados de la ecuación y no me estás
dejando cambiar de color
no no me está dejando que ahora
esto es sea al cuadrado ahora tomamos la
raíz cuadrada de ambos lados del lado
izquierdo tenemos raíz de 2 se queda
igual y raíz de x al cuadrado será x
entonces tenemos x x raíz de 2 es igual
a c es cierto x x raíz de 2 es igual a c
por lo tanto si tú tienes un triángulo
rectángulo isósceles sean cuáles sean
las medidas de los lados iguales la
hipotenusa será igual a raíz de 2 por la
longitud del lado en este caso tenemos
que es igual a x x raíz de 2 por ejemplo
si tú tienes un triángulo que se mira
algo así bueno de hecho lo voy a dibujar
un poco diferente para es bueno
orientarnos de distintas maneras si nos
topamos con un triángulo rectángulo
donde sus otros dos ángulos miden 45 45
si yo te digo que este lado tiene
longitud
este de aquí también el otro tiene
longitud 3 no no es necesario que lo
aclare por qué buenos isósceles entonces
estos dos lados miden lo mismo y de
hecho tampoco es necesario aplicar el
teorema de pitágoras porque es bueno
saber que la hipotenusa en este
triángulo el lado opuesto al ángulo de
90 grados será la raíz de 2 por 3
entonces esto de aquí vale 3 x raíz de 2
por lo tanto la razón de los lados de la
hipotenusa en un triángulo de 40 y 55 90
o lo que es lo mismo un triángulo
rectángulo isósceles la razón entre los
lados son 12 lados puede valer 1
entonces también el otro vale 1 tiene la
misma medida y la hipotenusa será raíz
de dos por la longitud de cualquiera de
los lados así que la razón es 11 raíz de
esto es para un triángulo de 45 45 90
esas son las razones y bueno ahora como
repaso también también si tienes un
triángulo de 30 60 90 las razones son de
1 raíz de 3 y 2
ahora vamos a aplicar todo esto en otros
vídeos